y todos
[Música]
hola hoy en science lic la teoría
cuántica de campos
a diferencia de una canica que posee una
habitación bien definida a escala
microscópica una partícula no la posee
su presencia se distribuye por el
espacio con mayor o menor probabilidad
esta descripción de las partículas
mediante ondas de probabilidad es lo que
se conoce como la mecánica cuántica por
su parte esta teoría permite describir
la evolución de una partícula a lo largo
del tiempo
pero esta descripción por muy eficaz que
sea no tomo en cuenta dos factores por
un lado la mecánica cuántica no permite
describir situaciones en las que el
número de partículas varía con el tiempo
en la naturaleza se observa que éstas
pueden aparecer o desaparecer por
ejemplo cuando un fotón es absorbido por
un electrón de un átomo
por otro lado la mecánica cuántica
considera cada partícula como si fuera
única e independiente no obstante dentro
de la misma familia de partículas como
por ejemplo los electrones todas
presentan las mismas propiedades como es
posible que un electrón de los confines
del cosmos tenga exactamente la misma
masa y carga que un electrón de una
manzana
para responder a esta pregunta tendremos
que construir un nuevo marco matemático
una descripción más general que armonice
la mecánica cuántica y la relatividad
especial se trata de la teoría más
precisa para describir nuestro mundo
microscópico y en este vídeo la
construiremos juntos la teoría cuántica
de campos
para empezar consideremos un universo
vacío la relatividad nos enseña que el
tejido del universo es el espacio-tiempo
para simplificar representaremos sólo
dos dimensiones del espacio además de la
dimensión temporal
ahora nos gustaría colmar nuestro
universo de objetos de materia
anteriormente vimos que todas las
partículas del mismo tipo como es el
caso de todos los electrones parecen
perfectamente idénticas como si fuesen
tan solo manifestaciones de un mismo
objeto subyacente que llenaría todo el
universo un campo
así pues para añadir algún contenido a
nuestro universo empezaremos por
completarlo con un campo
en matemáticas un campo es una especie
de fluido que colma todo el
espacio-tiempo y cuyos puntos están
compuestos por un objeto matemático
se puede tratar de un campo de números
vectores u otros objetos más exóticos
dicho esto la relatividad especial
impone restricciones nos obliga a
respetar ciertas simetrías que
corresponden a la geometría del
espacio-tiempo
las simetrías por traslación rotación o
cambio de marco de referencia
[Música]
estas simetrías son solo respetadas por
ciertos objetos matemáticos y podemos
clasificarlos con un parámetro su espín
los objetos más sencillos autorizados
son los números se les da el spin 0
porque cuando rotamos el espacio
alrededor de un número este no varía
[Música]
los vectores en cambio indican una
dirección en el espacio y su aspecto
depende de la orientación en la que se
observan se les da un spin 1 porque
cuando se rota el espacio de una vuelta
completa los vectores también lo hacen
por último la relatividad también admite
otros objetos más exóticos en particular
los spin hores de spin 1 sobre 2 son
necesarias dos vueltas alrededor de un
espino para que vuelva a su estado
inicial
todos estos objetos matemáticos pueden
parecer abstractos y algunos difíciles
de entender pero en principio todos
obedecen a las simetrías de la
relatividad y por lo tanto son
candidatos potenciales para ocupar
nuestro universo
además de imponer los tipos de objetos
permitidos las simetrías del
espacio-tiempo también restringen la
forma en que se disponen los objetos del
campo
cada simetría exige que el campo respeta
la conservación de una determinada
magnitud a lo largo del tiempo
para respetar la relatividad nuestro
campo debe respetar la conservación de
la energía
de la cantidad de movimiento del momento
angular y de la velocidad del centro de
masa
además los mismos objetos matemáticos
pueden contener simetrías propias
si decidimos formar un campo con números
complejos por ejemplo la simetría
interna de estos implica la conservación
de otra magnitud en el tiempo
relacionada con la propia naturaleza de
los números complejos la carga eléctrica
[Música]
a estas alturas tenemos un
espacio-tiempo que hemos completado con
un campo que satisface todas las
condiciones impuestas por la relatividad
especial
pero nuestro objetivo es describir el
mundo microscópico así que ha llegado el
momento de transformar nuestro campo en
un campo cuántico
en la mecánica cuántica para transformar
un objeto clásico en un objeto cuántico
se le permite adoptar varias posiciones
al mismo tiempo con mayor o menor
probabilidad
de forma similar para transformar un
campo clásico en un campo cuántico le
permitiremos adoptar varias
configuraciones varias posibilidades de
evolución con mayor o menor importancia
en el transcurso del tiempo nuestro
campo evoluciona en una superposición de
todos los escenarios posibles
la transición de un campo class con un
campo cuántico conduce una propiedad muy
interesante
al igual que un electrón en un átomo
tiene niveles discretos de energía bien
precisos un campo cuántico también los
tiene
solo puede contener un número entero de
perturbaciones cuántos de energía que
pueden aparecer o desaparecer
se trata de partículas
[Música]
al igual que una ola en la superficie
del agua una partícula simplemente una
perturbación que se propaga por el campo
[Música]
un campo cuántico también será quitado
por fluctuaciones que aparecen y
desaparecen continuamente lo que se
denomina partículas virtuales
estas partículas virtuales solo existen
durante un tiempo muy breve por lo que
es estrictamente imposible observarlas
y poco a poco nuestro modelo de universo
se acerca a la realidad ahora
descubrimos un espacio-tiempo colmado de
un campo cuántico dentro del cual las
perturbaciones y las partículas se
desplazan a una sopa de fluctuaciones
las partículas virtuales
en nuestro universo coexisten varios
campos que constituyen diferentes
familias de partículas
algunos son campos vectoriales de spin 1
en las partículas que contienen son
fotones bosones z y w y gluones
otros son campos de espinar es se trata
de los fermines que componen la materia
quarks electrones mont está wones y
neutrinos
por último hay un campo de spin 0 el
campo de higgs
la mayoría de estos campos tiene
simetrías internas que les confieren
magnitudes conservadas en el tiempo se
trata de cargas que diferencia sus
partículas en diversas versiones hemos
visto anteriormente que los campos del
número complejos poseen una simetría que
les confiere la carga eléctrica
esta simetría diferenciar a sus
partículas en dos versiones una con
carga positiva y otra con carga negativa
a esto se le llama antimateria en cierto
modo una antipartícula es el conjugado
complejo de una partícula ordinaria
algunos campos presentan simetrías más
exóticas los campos de quarks por
ejemplo tienen otra carga la carga de
color que también debe conservarse en el
tiempo y que permite distinguir entre
tres versiones de quarks denominadas
rojo verde y azul
al conjunto de estos campos que
conforman el contenido en nuestro
universo se le conoce como modelo
estándar de la física de partículas
en la actualidad es la descripción mejor
comprobada de nuestro universo a escala
microscópica
[Música]
nuestro modelo de universo contiene
ahora las mismas partículas que nuestro
universo real
sin embargo sigue si se realista las
simetrías de la relatividad imponen a
las partículas un movimiento rectilíneo
indefinido e independiente de las demás
para completar por fin nuestro modelo
del universo solo tenemos que añadir un
ingrediente fundamental más debemos
autorizar que estos campos interactúen
entre sí
para entenderlo mejor centrémonos en una
de las interacciones más sencillas la
que se produce entre el campo en fotones
y el campo de electrones
permitiremos que un electrón emita o
absorba un fotón virtual y viceversa
permitir esta simple interacción tendrá
consecuencias drásticas
ilustradas en la siguiente situación
empecemos con los electrones inmóviles
en el transcurso del tiempo los dos
electrones avanzan hacia el futuro a
primera vista se podría pensar que los
dos electrones permanecen inmóviles
indefinidamente pero esto sería olvidar
que nuestros electrones están
constantemente sumergidos en el campo de
fotones con el que se les ha permitido
interactuar
hemos visto que un campo cuántico
realiza todas las evoluciones posibles
al mismo tiempo en cierto modo cada
configuración describe un escenario y en
particular en algunos de estos
escenarios los electrones interactúan
con el campo de fotones
[Música]
en este escenario el electrón emite un
fotón virtual en el momento determinado
éste lleva consigo parte del movimiento
del electrón y el fotón virtual está
absorbido un poco más tarde por el otro
electrón
en este otro escenario los electrones
intercambian dos fotones virtuales
o en este tercer y más complejo
escenario el electrón emite un fotón
virtual que se convierte en un par
virtual electrón positrón que se
aniquilará en un nuevo fotón virtual que
finalmente es absorbido por el segundo
electrón
al intercambiar parte de su movimiento
gracias a las partículas virtuales los
dos electrones se acercarán en ocasiones
y se alejarán en otras
[Música]
consideremos la analogía siguiente en
una guitarra una cuerda puede vibrar con
diferentes frecuencias cada una de las
cuales corresponde a un sonido puro
pero cuando se pulsa la cuerda ésta
empieza a vibrar con una superposición
de todas estas frecuencias con mayor o
menor amplitud es la síntesis de todos
estos tonos puros que se suman con mayor
o menor amplitud lo que constituye el
sonido total producido por la cuerda
del mismo modo un campo cuántico
evoluciona según todos los escenarios
posibles con mayor o menor amplitud y es
la síntesis de todos estos escenarios la
que describe la evolución real del
sistema físico
en particular en nuestro ejemplo cuando
sumamos todas estas posibilidades
constatamos que nuestros dos electrones
se alejan uno del otro poco a poco
estos experimentan una fuerza que los
aleja debido a intercambios fotones
virtuales es la fuerza electromagnética
en cambio si hubiéramos empezado con un
electrón y un positrón de cargas
opuestas las amplitudes de los distintos
escenarios habrían sido diferentes dando
lugar esta vez a una fuerza global
atractiva
[Música]
al permitir que las partículas
interactúen e intercambien cantidades de
movimiento la teoría cuántica de campos
explica cómo las fuerzas surgen a partir
de simetrías simples las simetrías de
los campos que constituyen nuestro
universo
en conclusión la teoría cuántica de
campos es una receta matemática para
construir un modelo del universo
comenzamos con un espacio-tiempo que
completamos con campos cuánticos que
satisfacen las simetrías de la
relatividad especial
la teoría cuántica de campos permite así
construir una descripción cuántica de
nuestro universo que respete las
restricciones impuestas por la
relatividad al permitir que los campos
interactúen entre sí esta teoría permite
predecir los fenómenos que rigen nuestro
universo con una precisión asombrosa
según la teoría cuántica de campos la
evolución de nuestro universo es en
cierto modo una síntesis de todos los
escenarios posibles a nivel microscópico
sin embargo esta descripción sigue
siendo incompleta porque aunque
satisfaga la relatividad especial la
teoría cuántica de campos no puede
verificarse con la relatividad general
que describe la gravitación por la
curvatura del espacio-tiempo
algunos resultados de la teoría se
pueden aplicar ya al espacio tiempo
curvo como la predicción de que los
agujeros negros se evaporan con el
tiempo
pero los científicos buscan una teoría
única que explique fundamentalmente de
dónde procede esta curvatura y que
unifique lo infinitamente grande y lo
infinitamente pequeño una teoría del
todo
[Música]